hey guys chesty here Friday the 13th the
game is out now and it's based on the
long-running movie franchise so there
are bound to be lots and lots of Easter
eggs we're going to show you what we
found so far from the different versions
of Jason to all those classic kills but
first please check out GameSpot universe
it's our home for everything that you
like besides games movies TV anime
comics all the things so check it out by
clicking right up there
good job
[Music]
in Friday the 13th the game you can play
a six different movie versions of Jason
Voorhees you can choose from Jason and
Friday to the 13th part 2 part 3 part 6
Jason lives part 7 the new blood
part 8 Jason Takes Manhattan and part 9
Jason goes to hell there's also a new
version of Jason designed by Tom Savini
created for the game
for the original Friday the 13th
director Sean Cunningham shot many
scenes in the dark to maintain a feeling
of suspense to highlight important
details bright colored items were used
like wooden doors that were painted red
and yellow raincoats to identify
characters
Friday the 13th the game will be
released with three playable maps to
start with each of these maps are
locations from the movies the Higgins
Haven map which we saw during the beta
is a location from Friday the 13th part
3 and the final chapter
Higgins Haven was the property of Chris
Higgins and family located on the shore
of Crystal Lake this is where the second
stage of the Crystal Lake massacre took
place in 1984 the Camp Crystal Lake map
is made up of a few areas from parts one
through six the fictional summer camp
located in new jersey is the home of
Jason Voorhees what was once a thriving
summer camp became a cursed place
infamous for brutal murders massacres
and supernatural occurrences the pack
and a collage map is inspired by the
same location in Friday the 13th part
two this group of rustic cabins is
located in the woods at Crystal Lake a
quick walk from Camp Crystal Lake pack
and neck Lodge was the site of Jason's
first murders in 1984 where he killed
nearly an entire training class of
summer camp counselors
[Music]
Tommy Jarvis a character in three of the
films is playable in the game if you
play as a counselor and use the radio in
the game someone will respond as Tommy
Jarvis from the movies Tommy was the
male protagonist in Friday the 13th the
final chapter a new beginning and part
six Jason lives Tommy was the first
person to defeat Jason when he stabbed
Jason with his own machete in Friday the
13th the final chapter
[Music]
as a counselor you can find and use bear
traps in the game but be careful because
you might get stuck in one in the 2009
remake of Friday the 13th a counselor
named Richie gets his leg stuck in
Jason's bear trap right before he gets a
machete to the head there are a lot of
brutal executions in Friday's 13th the
game including a few lifted from the
movies during one game we got our head
punched off which was taken straight
from this rooftop scene in part eight
Jason Takes Manhattan
[Music]
be careful when hiding in the tent
because Jason will drag you out in your
sleeping bag and smash your body against
a tree just like how poor camper Judi
met her fate in part seven the new blood
[Music]
at the end of every match when Jason
wins you'll see Jason's shrine to his
mother Pamela Voorhees this shrine was
featured in Friday the 13th part two
inside Jason's Shack
it contains Pamela's head the sweater
that she wore when she was killed and
the machete used to kill her let us know
if you found any other Easter eggs in
the comments below and also hang out
with me over on GameSpot universe we
covered alien covenant if that's your
jam if not we also cover a lot of TV a
lot of other scary stuff like twin
peaks' that show gets real scary
sometimes so I'll see you there